The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: Jonathan
sent an email.
If you have questions, you
still need a clarification,
you send him.
But say we still expect you to--
you decide to redo it,
you should do it yourself.
There are no discussions.
You can go back and
look at any books.
But you do it yourself.
OK?
Any clarification on it?
OK, so then let's come back.
I spend-- this is the chapter--
I spent the most time, in
terms of per chapter so far.
We're really talking
about the transport law.
And the content that
we talk to is best
applied to ballistic transport,
meaning there is no scatter.
You can still
treat with scatter.
But I say, right now,
what we're saying
is if I want to know the
transport between any two
points, and now
the transmittance.
So we learned how to calculate
transmittance of interface,
and how transmittance
of film, multilayer,
vacuums, tunneling--
all those, in theory,
now you can at
least say you're not
afraid of dealing with
these type of problems.
So if the transmittance and
the left flux, whatever flux.
Here I'm doing the heat flux.
So h bar omega is energy.
And so I'm doing 1
to 2 minus 2 to 1.
But at the end, apply the
principle of detailed balance.
Which is essentially second law.
It says at an equilibrium,
the lead flux must be zero.
And otherwise you have
created an imbalance.
Heat can go spontaneously
from form hot and cold sides.
So that's not valid and
that's the principle
of detailed balance.
So essentially, you can say,
when we want to calculate flux,
is the velocity, transmittance,
the quantity that
are transported here
is what mode, right,
quantum state, and
then the distribution
function difference.
It states how many
particles we have
either corresponding
temperature, chemical
potential, and of
course, the energy.
So the detailed
balance really saved us
from calculating both
sides because let's say
you can take any of the sides
and do your calculation as
long as you know
the transmittance
from the starting side to the
other side or other point.
And I emphasized at the
end of last lecture,
those kinds of transport,
there a high-low equilibrium.
So it's actually
hard to really define
a quantity that we're used to.
Even temperature,
chemical potential, those
are all thermodynamic
quantities.
And the example we spent
some time to explain
is thermal boundary resistance.
When I have acoustic wave
comes toward the interface,
on this side this is--
in fact, this is my T1, the
corresponding distribution
of phonons coming from this side
and refracted and transmitted.
And on the other side
I have the incoming
with the characteristic
temperature
at T2 reflected and transmitted.
So locally, I do not
have at the interface,
on each side of interface,
I do not have equilibrium.
And when I force my
temperature definition,
this temperature,
the local energy,
is not actually just a T1
characteristics, but also
transmission of T2
characteristics.
So if you redefine
a local temperature,
or if you do charge
transfer, a local chemical
potential,
electrochemical potential,
it's not the incoming one.
And you have to recalculate
what's the local--
for example, if I want
the first temperature
to be equivalent measure
of a local energy density,
I will define the
local temperature
based on local energy density.
That gives me a different
temperature than this one.
So those are [INAUDIBLE]
equilibrium process.
I think the best
way you understand
this is taking the undergraduate
problem of blackbody radiation.
If I have two black surfaces.
And this is T1 and this is T2.
And now if you
look at the inside,
I have photons come
in from 1 to 2.
And this has a
characteristic temperature 1.
And then I have photons
go in the other side
and have a characteristic
of temperature 2.
And then you ask, what's
the photon temperature?
You say there's no
equilibrium, clearly.
You can't define a photon
temperature inside.
And now you say, OK, imagine I
have a detector with two face.
Both side is black.
So I have a small detector
with both sides are black.
On one side, it absorbs
the temperature of heat
from with the temperature T1.
The other side was
the temperature T2.
And you have an
equilibrium temperature
here because of the
absorber thermalize, right,
those two temperatures,
two groups of photons.
And that temperature
is a flat inside.
It's because there's no change.
It depends on going from
one side to the other.
There's no change.
So if you say, OK, my define--
the photon conductance, if
I define based on the photon
temperature here,
are the two sides,
you know there's no delta T and
your conductance are infinite.
But if I define, based on
the temperature of the solid,
I can measure this easily.
I don't have that detector.
But I can define--
if I put in my
thermocouple to measure
to solid surfaces, solid objects
to black body, I'll measure T1,
I'll measure T2.
My thermocouple is not measuring
the photon temperature.
my thermocouple is measuring
the solid temperature.
In fact my thermocouple
is measuring the phonon
temperature.
So you're actually
fooled in this case.
But that's whether you-- in your
engineering calculation, that's
the definition you'll be using.
So this is the temperature
you'll be using.
You're using the
solid temperature.
So I gave another
example where say
people measure the
conductance of a wire,
electric conductance.
They put the two metal
probe-- for example,
you do a carbon nanotube.
You put a two big electrodes.
You measure voltage here.
That's like you're measuring
the two solid temperatures.
You can't measure the electron
chemical potential exactly
at the contact.
You don't have a
probe that easily
measure that local voltage.
If you measure that
local voltage, again,
the electron in the
ballistic regime,
there is no voltage drop.
You should get an
infinite conductance.
So this definition dependent,
when you do your experiment,
you need to know what
they're comparing to.
Don't compare oranges
with apples, OK?
So with this, basically
you can really,
if you do nanoscale
transport, this
could be a foundation
to understand
a lot of papers in literature.
People are studying different
kinds of nanoscale transport
problems.
We're talking about conductance
and many other examples.
So just to take the
carbon nanotube.
And if you write down let's say
the electrical conductivity,
so there is this a
universal conductance.
And turns out that
universal conductance,
for one-dimensional object, it
doesn't depend on the material.
And the conductance G per mole,
per quantum channel, quantum
state, is a e squared h bar--
let me check, what
are the other factor?
2?
[INAUDIBLE] e squared, pi h bar.
So if you substitute a Lambert,
this conductance or equivalent
resistance, which is the
inverse of the conductance
is 12,265 ohm.
OK, so through each channel,
you add another channel,
you have two parallel channel.
They conductance doubles,
resistance reduced by half,
the quantum states.
So people have, in the
past, they measure--
in fact, there
was the experiment
doing say various
quantum transport
particle at low temperatures.
And this is electrical.
And you can do thermal.
If I have two temperature
difference between two points,
and the thermal conductance
for one-dimensional object
is pi kb squared T
and divide by 6 h bar.
And this one-- so this
is, again, universal
because it doesn't have a
material property there.
And if you plug in your Lambert
conductance here, I get about--
this 10 to the 12th times T and
the Watt meters squared Kelvin.
So this number will be
interesting for some
of my students doing the
interface resistance.
We the--
Oh, this is a positive 12--
well, let me see.
Negative 12-- wait, I
have some number problem.
Pi kb T square, kb 46, 10 to
the minus 12 T and Watt meter
squared.
So the-- no I think I
have to check this number.
It doesn't look right because
G typically is 10 to the 9th,
this is minus 12.
So maybe I'll check.
I don't know where
it's wrong now.
OK so that's the
universal conductance.
And if we do, for example, we do
near field, I have two plates.
And I have typically,
the wave comes in,
and it has reflection,
and has transmission.
We said that when
the two surfaces are
brought the close by, you
have [INAUDIBLE] phenomena.
And again, with that, you
can calculate transmittance.
And you do your integration
over all states,
you can get the increase
of the heat transfer
due to the tunneling.
Or if you're interested in
charge, the electrical charge
tunneling, all those
can be done now.
So I think it will be--
I encourage now, you
can look at literature.
People study all those different
nanostructure, conductance,
transport.
And this is very
often discussed.
What I have not finished
is what's the velocity.
It turns out this
one is actually a one
that we ask at the beginning,
how fast the particle really
travels.
So let's discuss this
velocity, group velocity.
And this is a concept
sometimes very
hard to appreciate,
to understand.
What is a group velocity?
So definition wise, it
would be relatively easy.
But why we see
the group velocity
is typically when we use--
when we calculate
the charge, the heat,
that's the velocity I do in
my v, vx here, for example.
Why I use group velocity?
So first, let me take a
picture of phonon dispersion
where in specific direction
I have k, I have omega,
and I have acoustic
phonon, one branch only.
I'm looking at it.
And the group velocity is
tangent of every point.
And that's the group velocity.
And it's this velocity
we use when we
stop into the energy transport.
That's how fast--
how much energy say
a phonon would carry at that
specific mode, frequency.
Why I use that velocity?
First let's look at
a wave, because I've
been talking about plane
wave representation, right?
So a wave that I usually
use, either vector or scalar.
Now I just write a
simple scalar wave
is a minus i omega t minus kx.
I'm assuming that k is in
the x direction, simple.
And this is the plane wave
representation I have.
What's the origin of my time--
was the end of the time
here for two plane wave?
That's minus infinite
to plus infinite.
That's a true plane wave.
There's no ending point.
Any time I have
an ending point, I
don't just have one
single frequency there.
So for example, if I
have a periodic signal,
I can say this is omega 0.
But only has a finite
time span, right?
Let's say t0.
It only has a finite time span.
And normally you say, OK,
I have a periodic signal.
But mathematically,
that's not quite correct,
because this signal does
not go from minus infinite
to plus infinite.
And if I have periodic signal or
only segment of time or length,
I can do Fourier series.
So you can do your
Fourier analysis.
And you see the real
frequency of this wave
is not-- a let's
say here the omega
0 is my fundamental
frequency of this wave.
And then I have omega 0.
I have harmonics.
Omega 0 will be
my highest modes.
And the 2 0, and the--
so different the frequency
around the central frequency.
That's why I do the
Fourier analysis.
OK, so now, because of this,
because in a solid or whatever,
there's never really a wave
that go from minus infinite
to plus infinite.
The generators, for example,
the atomic vibration or electron
transition from high
energy to low energy,
they only spend a
certain amount of time.
Or the event only spends
a certain amount of time.
So I have to
consider what happens
when the actual event is,
for example, happening
at a short time.
And in this case, I have
multiple frequencies, not just
one single frequency.
So if I have multiple
frequencies--
let's look at the simplest--
if I just have two
frequencies, what happens?
Let's say one frequency is
omega 0 plus delta omega.
And correspondingly, I
have k0 plus delta k,
because it's not linear.
So I have omega 0 minus delta
omega and k0 minus delta k.
So those are two different
waves with slightly different--
they all centralize to omega 0,
but they are small spreading,
delta omega delta k.
And now I have--
really what's propagating
this simultaneously two
waves I generated and the
superposition of these two
waves.
So if I look at the
superimposed wave, a--
I'm assuming they are
same amplitude just
to make life simpler--
and a minus i omega
0 plus delta omega
t minus k plus the delta kx k0
and plus the other frequency
and the wave vector is minus
i omega 0 minus delta omega
t minus k0 minus delta k x.
And I have the superposition
of this real signal that
propagated in the media because
it has two waves in the signal.
And when I add this up, you
have a central frequency omega
k0 I can pull out.
Then I have a plus term, a
minus term in the exponent.
So you do your
algebra, what you get
is a 2a cosine delta omega times
t delta k times x, and then
exponential minus i
omega 0t minus k0 x.
So this is the
result of when I have
two waves with a small
separation in frequency
and wave vector.
And you look at this
now what's propagating,
here I have a high frequency
omega 0 k0 central one.
Here I have not a cosine that
modulates this frequency.
So what I really have is
a cosine signal that's
delta omega delta k, so
which is slower, typically.
And then this is the
amplitude of the--
so at the center, I have
omega 0 k0 modulated.
So this is the FM signal.
Is it AM or FM?
AM signal.
You're modulating the amplitude
of the central frequency,
right?
So now I have the
outer envelope, which
is cosine omega t minus kx.
Now if you think
about what energy--
say the pointing vector.
For example, when I think
about electromagnetic wave,
my pointing vector is E
cross H. And of course I
have one half real part of that.
Now if I have this term inside
equals H, E has this term.
H complex conjugate also has
this term, but as a plus.
That this term actually drop
out when you do equals H.
So what it is really,
then, the energy
is actually the front term here.
So what energies are propagated
is like, in this case,
it's a slower
packet propagating.
That's a wave packet.
And the speed of this
propagation-- now
if I look at this
factor there, is dx dt.
So the dx dt is
delta omega delta k.
So this is actually whether the
propagation-- this wave packet
is propagating at this
speed, new speed there.
And this speed in the limit
of very narrow of delta omega
delta k, I have
derivative, right?
So this equals d omega dk and
this is my Vg, group velocity.
That's why I'm doing
the group velocity.
And when I do transport, I
use V, the group velocity.
The phase velocity
is omega over k.
That's this triangle here.
That's the phase velocity.
And in fact, if you go to
check your density of states,
when you calculate
density of states,
you want phase velocity.
You want both phase
velocity and group velocity.
OK, but so when I
do transport-- when
I think about how fast the
particle or energy is going
from one place to
other, the wave packet,
and I should use
the group velocity
for the actual transport speed.
And when I calculate it,
when I convert these modes
into density of states,
I should be careful,
some is the group velocity,
some is the phase velocity.
And of course, this is
the only one direction.
And the three directions, in
general, the group velocity
is a vector.
So this one is, for
example, if you do Cartesian
coordinate for the k space is d
omega dk x kx and d omega dk y
ky and D omega dk z kz.
So that's a general
group velocity.
And with that, you can say--
now if I go back
to phonons, and I
have the optical
phonon, acoustic phonon.
If you look at the group
velocity, very small k.
This one, the tangent
here, is much larger.
Then at the end of the k,
zone boundary, k [INAUDIBLE]
is 0, flat.
So here is a speed of sound
that they can measure.
And here is zone boundary
group velocity for 0.
So the acoustic phonon
group velocity is changing.
Optical phonon,
the group velocity
is typically very
small, even though they
phase velocity is very high.
Omega over k, omega
is very large.
Phase velocity is
large is large.
But group velocity
is very small.
And when you do
specific heat, it
turns out the simple Debye model
or plus Einstein model is fine.
But when you do
transport, this velocity
becomes more important.
So even though most models
in literature, and in fact,
90% of those papers you
check now, you'll notice,
we typically simplify the
Debye model or Einstein model
when we do heat transfer
thermal conductivity.
But that will typically lead
to very different results
from reality because of the
use of the group velocity here.
It's a major factor.
And this is the case of phonons.
And you can also--
so you think about electrons.
So for example, I have electron.
This is the energy.
This is the k.
That's typical dispersion.
And so the center, the minimum,
the group velocity is 0.
This is because it's
a parabolic bend.
We said that some
electron, in fact,
in the problem in the midterm,
with some of this graphene,
they have let's say
a linear dispersion.
So either k equals 0 or
the velocity is not 0.
But say most time, this
is 0 and velocity is 0.
So if you think about it the
parabolic bend, the group
velocity--
let's say here kx is d omega.
Omega is E over h bar, right,
that's omega, and d kx,
let's say in the x direction.
And E, if it's a parabolic
bend, then you can say
is h bar kx over m.
So this is P over
m, momentum divided
by mass, that's consistent when
we have in the classical limit.
But on the other
hand, if you say OK,
my E equals h bar squared
k squared over 2m,
so this is a team for
our parabolic event.
And if I just use the phrase
velocity all for this,
I will not gather the
same as group velocity.
So group velocity is like my
speed of the free particle
here, because the
phase velocity,
you get a factor
of 2 difference.
But there are some
interesting case.
This is actually, we always
say, most of the time,
that group velocity is the
one you calculate transport.
They are trickier cases
where this becomes very--
this is actually not right.
And if you check the literature
over probably the last 15
years, there are
actually discussion.
People will say,
well, some of this
goes over the speed
of light, right?
And in fact, if you look
at the optical constant,
we know that the speed of
light and media is c0 over n.
This is a phase velocity.
And it turns out that you
check the optical constant
of some media refractive
index, real part.
This is n.
This is omega.
And at some omega 0, you
may have-- this is a 1,
this is a 1--
and the sum of these
omega look like this--
refractive index, real part.
So what happens is here,
of course, a less than 1.
So the phase velocity is much
larger than the speed of light.
But that's fine.
You will say, OK, that's
not the energy velocity.
OK, so you're still comfortable.
But then if you go to take the
derivative of dn d say omega,
you'll find that even the
group velocity in this region
could be larger than 1.
So you run into, are
you violating Einstein's
relativity principle?
And the reason then,
is that, in this case,
it's actually not
the group velocity,
it's the energy velocity.
And when this
varies very rapidly,
when this omega 0 omega
over k varies very rapidly,
and those quantities is a
strong function of omega k,
so you cannot pull out and
do the analysis we do here.
So in that case, there is
actually a so-called signal
velocity.
And a few, about 15 more, I
remember probably in the '90s,
there are actually
some sensation.
People actually measure
some of the signal
first reach beyond
the speed of light.
Anything beyond the
speed of light and I say
is Einstein still valid?
Right?
Then so the people who do
the work who will say this
is a not a violation of
Einstein's relativity principle
because this is the
first part of the signal.
The signal has not
completely gone through it.
So even though the front
of the signal comes,
but not all the information
has to be transferred.
So you are still not violating
the Einstein principle.
But there are a lot of
news coverage all the time.
And so anyway,
that's a sidetrack.
So that's why when we
do the calculation,
we will use the group velocity.
So we have now the answer to
pretty much all the questions.
Say how fast?
That's group velocity.
Say how many?
Density of states.
And each state, the
distribution function.
And so with those, say how
far, and in certain case,
those transmission tells us
how much is going forward,
how much backward.
And where we're
going next is here
or the discussion is
based on the wave picture.
But if you think about
the mechanical engineer,
a lot of the equations
you learned so far
was based on wave picture.
How do we go from that wave to
completely ignoring the wave,
to treat them as particles.
So this is another
very, very deep subject.
And it's one that people are
still doing a lot of research
on.
And I'm going to
give you my best
shot at making a
transition of forgetting
those phase of the wave,
and go into the particle.
So one of my objective
is for you to see
when you should get varied.
Either which domain
you should be
varied about wave effects
or classical size effect
and you feel comfortable using
your continuum equations.
So that's one of my objectives.
And now I'm shooting at,
after group velocity,
is wave to particle transition.
And this is where I see,
we're still, for example,
even though we're
writing-- trying
to write a good paper on it.
And there are many ISE concepts
that I learned before, I
had to revise it constantly.
So it's a picture that
hard to actually clarify.
And a lot of research being done
in different aspects of this.
So the question is, when
I deal with the wave,
I solve Maxwell's equation, I
solve crystal wave equation.
And the question is,
when can I neglect them?
When I do the wave, I carry
the phase that complex Lambert
here--
it gives me a lot of
variation, which is good.
If you want the variation,
that's most beautiful.
But say, when can I neglect it.
And let me go back to
what I mentioned before
that in reality you do
not have extended wave,
you have wave packet, right?
So in material, right.
I have an atom jiggling locally.
It emits a time signal, a pulse.
And there could
be a pulse length
over a certain amount
of time, and also
over a certain spatial extent.
So this is a wave
packet composed
of a lot of frequencies.
And let's say there is the
frequency spread is delta nu
And in optics, there is
definition of coherence length.
And in fact, there's coherence
is a very extensively discussed
in optics books.
If you want to
understand coherence,
you should read that.
And there is a
quantum coherence.
There's classical coherence.
And there's spatial coherence.
There's time coherence.
And here, I'm giving the
simplest, the time coherence.
So if I have a wave packet
that has a frequency spread,
then there is also
corresponding space spread,
because they have propagated
in different velocity.
So this space spread
is coherent length.
This is of the order of c
delta nu, the speed of light
divided by the spread.
That gives you the length scale.
So physically, this wave packet
also covers some length scale.
And the space coherence
is at two points
whether the wave packet
are correlated or not.
And typically with a
random thermal source,
for example, I have vibration--
atomic vibration-- here
and another place,
I typically just
ignore this spatial coherence.
The two vibrations are
spatially uncorrelated.
But there are other cases where
they are actually correlated.
OK but say what I
actually have a lot
of misunderstanding myself
over this process, many years--
But first, let's say I
mentioned that-- if you recall--
if I have a wave packet, if
I have a perfect interface,
and it comes through
the interface.
And some of this
was transmitted.
And you can see that is still
the same packet transmitted,
reflected.
Some of this is reflected.
So at that 0 thickness
at the interface,
the reflection and
incoming are spatial--
so they're correlated.
This is the same wave packet.
So you have to, if it's a
perfect interface there,
you have to use your wave
mechanics to deal with.
It's a wave, right?
So that's a single
simple interface.
Then what about a film?
So if I think about
a film of thickness d
and my wave packet
comes in, I'm looking at
to treat them the same, because
if they are the same, if they
overlap spatially, you have to
include that phase addition.
They interfere with each other.
If they come from
different wave packet,
they are not correlated, because
the one that the immediate--
say in the next
time step may not
be correlated with the
one that are emitted
by the previous time step.
So two different wave
packet, I don't care.
I consider the
one that somewhere
coming from a source
propagating inside the film
and now reflected.
So whether I consider
interference or not,
then this is the
same wave packet.
Maybe different amplitude, but
they come from the same parent.
So if they spatially
overlap, you
have to include
the interference.
You have to use the
wave superposition
that we did before.
So one of the
criteria is if this d
is a much larger then
coherence length,
if this is very large, the
same wave packet-- of course
at the interface, I have to
use that Fresnel formula,
which is a wave result.
But once they are
away from interframe,
most of the region in
the film, like a window,
this packet will not overlap.
So you can just trace them
as particles, trajectories.
Forget about the phase,
because you do phase,
you'll get the same result.
So that's one scenario.
In fact, I thought that was
the most scenario when I was--
the first paper when I
was a student, I wrote--
a PhD student--
I wrote was on this problem.
And I thought that would answer
the wave particle transition.
And in fact, in optics--
so there are two ways.
One is the transfer matrix
to calculate reflectance.
The other is just completely
ignore the interference
and do retracing energy
bounce back and forth.
But you look at the formula,
it's very different.
So I actually was just
a [INAUDIBLE] formula.
And then my advisor say, oh,
you should look at theories.
So I went to check it
turns out there is all
this optical coherence theory.
And I use the theory.
And I say that's the transition.
So this is where the
demarcation comes from.
Film is thick.
You neglect to say inference--
film is thin.
You don't need [INAUDIBLE].
It's all very logical.
But then, years later, I
realized this is a problem.
Other people probably
know this very well.
But the problem is if I have a
black body, which has a spread,
and in fact, you can calculate
the effect of spread.
The black body has a--
it's opaque.
You say 0 to infinite
of the frequency,
but they can calculate
effective bandwidth of that 0
to infinite because it
peaks around [INAUDIBLE]..
But see when I calculate
the multilayer structure,
particularly
superlattice, we mentioned
before, Bragg reflector.
Bragg reflector is a 1-2
1-2 repeating structure.
And it turns out that you
really don't get this result.
The limit [INAUDIBLE]
are very thick.
You still get your
wave result. You
can never get the result of
where you neglect completely
the interference effect.
So I thought about this.
And now the physical explanation
is, again, is the same parent--
the wave packet came
from the same parent
that actually overlap.
Why?
If you say, OK, here I
have a packet comes in.
And they go into
the first layer.
And that packet
and reflect once,
refract to the second
layer, reflect once.
This from the split from the
same parent packet there.
Of course, because
of the time delay,
I don't have overlap between
this one and this one,
because this one already--
this one travel longer time.
So when this wave packet
coming into this layer,
this one already gone off.
However, but this one has
a lot of reflection here,
another reflection,
back and that's
coming from the same parent.
And these two can
spatially overlap.
And here, even though
you have very thick one,
they can still interfere
with each other.
So your structure actually
gave this packet a coherence.
So you cannot completely just
use the simple coherence length
to neglect the wave effect.
So that's say a lesson
learned in optics.
And the next lesson is the
phonon scatter, which we'll
dive in in the next lecture.
And phonon-phonon
scatter-- so we'll
have the lattice vibration.
And they are typically three
phonon interaction process.
So in this case, what I
have is inelastic scatter.
So now you have to
look at the scatter.
So inelastic scatter
is when I have
one phonon omega 1,
two phonon on comes in,
and they interact and
forms third phonon
and the energy of the third
is the sum of [INAUDIBLE]..
Those kind of process pops
up randomly in the solid,
because the phonon propagate
anywhere they are not fixed.
So those processes are usually
consider as a phase destroying.
So inelastic
scattering-- typically,
if your process is dominated
by inelastic scattering,
and that gives you the,
let's say, the mu free path,
the distance between
the scattering event.
And of course, the
scattering itself,
will [INAUDIBLE] this
phase superposition.
But between one point and
to the other, the wave,
once they scatter, it
propagates as a packet.
The left system is scattered
to another direction
as a completely
different wave packet,
because they lose their
parent information.
It's random.
So in this case, I can
consider the waves--
I can forget about
the superposition
of waves between
different scatter waves.
So I trade them as particles,
uncorrelated particles.
So inelastic scattering is--
typically you can
trade as a particle,
if this process is dominant.
But there's another process.
For example, if I have
a solid or impurity atom
in the material, and
the wave comes in,
whether it's an electron
wave or a phonon wave.
This comes in and another
omega, it goes out,
and the same one goes.
They just change
direction, right?
This is a light, for
example, typically when you
have dust in the sky, the light
comes in, refract to your eye.
This kind of process, the
particle position is fixed.
But the scattering direction
depends on the solution.
You have to solve
the Maxwell equation
for that problem in a class
they call [INAUDIBLE] theory.
Or you solve the electron,
atom, all those problems because
of this guy is fixed.
So the scatter one actually
have a fixed phase relation.
Different direction, you
have different fixed wave.
So these are the
elastic scatter.
And typically, elastic
scattering really
does not destroy phase,
because let's say
this position is fixed.
It's just got
different direction
made a different phase.
But this one, this one has
a fixed phase relationship.
So then the question is, do
I treat them as particles
if this one is dominant?
Turns out that here, you've
got really complicated
possibilities.
For example, you
have many particles.
And you can have a wave comes
in, and say scatter into here
and scatter into here.
And you could also
have waves scatter back
along the same paths
and completely cancel
the incoming wave.
So those kind of
wave superposition
is called localization.
So if it's an elastic scatter,
you can to have localization.
And you could also have where,
because at least each one
you can have complete
pattern of scattering even
though the different directions
are fixed with regarding
to the incoming one.
But when you consider
many of them,
spatially, they
are random enough
you actually can neglect
those phase superposition.
So in that case,
you can go again
into the particle picture.
If it's a localization,
you cannot.
But in the outer limit,
you can neglect the phase,
just treat them as particles.
OK here, you will
say when I can do it.
I can't tell you.
It's very complicated.
And the idea of if
you actually read,
because we discussed several
times, the photonic crystal.
And the photonic crystal,
that concept the name
was coined by Yablonovitch.
But in the same year,
there was another paper
studying the same phenomenon.
That's by John Sajeev.
And he was studying
the same structure.
And he wants to look at when
the wave gets localized.
So they're a completely
different angle
looking at the same problem.
So yeah, photonic
crystal is actually
typically accredited to
two people, Yablonovitch
and John Sajeev.
So you look at the
different literature,
it turns out in optics, people
talk a lot of coherence.
And of course, the electron
transport, a lot of people
also talk of coherence.
And one of the biggest problem
with the quantum computing
is how you can keep
the wave phase.
You don't lose the phase.
You lose the phase, your
superposition of waves is gone.
So to maintain the
face coherence time,
in electric-- if you
read the literature,
there are many
different lengths.
For example, there is this--
I think it's a very
Thouless length--
different length scales.
And of course, is there are
diffusion lengths, all those.
So talking about those
transition picture, very, very
complicated.
And we have been studying heat
conduction in superlattice.
And recently, we think we
have really found evidence
that there is a phase
coherence contribution
to thermal conductivity.
And there is another
very mysterious result
on thermal conductivity
of nanowires,
where there are some rough
nanowire people reporting
way below what the classical
size effect could predict.
And another paper being
written and some speculation
where the localization
is the reason or not.
But there is really
no strong proof.
So doing theory,
doing experiments
in all those regimes
are very difficult.
So given what I said--
so you see, this is an area
that needs more research.
You might be
interested in doing it.
But now I'm making
the transition.
I say I'm jumping
from the case where
I consider the phase of the
wave as I do in this chapter,
to the case in the next stage.
I'm going to trade all those
energy carriers as particles.
I completely ignore the phase.
This is a different
level of granularity.
Remember when we talk about
Einstein wave particle duality,
a wave is both
wave and particle.
It has momentum, it has a phase.
But what I'm saying
is that I'm migrating
into a classical regime
where I completely
drop out the phase information.
I look at trajectory
of those particles.
So this is where we're migrating
to the next chapter, chapter 6.
So chapter 6, they will start
talking about the transport
by particles.
And let's start with
a general equation,
in this case Liouville equation.
So Liouville equation
describes the particles
in a system, how they move.
And it's very general
because let's suppose that I
have n particles in the system.
And let's suppose that
each particle has say 2m.
Each particle, 2m
degree of freedom.
And this degrees of freedom
represented, for example,
if I have x, y, z in Cartesian
coordinate, translation
of degree of freedom.
I will also have vx, vy, vz.
So I have momentum.
I have coordinate,
space coordinate.
Or if you think of
angular, theta phi,
you have angular momentum.
So 2m means if I have
r, say i-th particle,
I have r1 to say r im.
This is space degree of freedom.
And correspondingly I have p.
I want p momentum im.
So I have two m.
I'm going to use a notation.
OK, my total number
of degree of freedom
is 2n equals 2m times N.
That's total number of degree
of freedom.
See, I have n particles
in the system, 10
to the 23rd,
Avogadro's constant.
If for each paragraph
is more atomic,
it's only doing translation.
So I have 6 because
the m is a 3 for xyz,
and the vx vy vz gives me six.
So each particle I need 6.
And 6 times the N
gives me a total number
of degree of freedom.
Say I use a generalized, so if
I general this one, I have 2n,
say rn and pn, those are
my generalized coordinates.
So if capital N is say
one avocado constant,
this is 6 because I just
explained, 6 n divided by 2
is 3n is the space coordinate
and momentum coordinate.
So this is a huge
number, high order space.
And each point, if I have
one point in that space,
I know the whole system,
because I know every particle's
position and momentum.
So now you have to
generalize your 3D to n
dimension, 2n dimension, and
nobody can do that, of course.
And this is my phase space.
So this one forms
my phase space.
OK and now if you
recall in chapter 4,
when we discussed the
generalized theory
of statistics, we
mentioned, now that I
say you don't need to really--
we're not to test
it, as you see.
But I did mention that
in ensemble concept.
So ensemble, if I
take a system, either
isolate it or
constant temperature,
or constant temperature
and constant number of--
constant chemical potential.
So I take it each quantum state.
Rather than the
time average, I do
each quantum state,
ensemble, it's
a one system in my ensemble.
So each quantum state
now has one set of rn pn,
because I know the
position, and now
the momentum of
all the particles.
So one set of rn pn.
And if I have many
quantum states,
I have that many
points in my phase /
So in my phase space,
now I can draw it.
So I'm going to
simplify my rn, my pn.
I have, in this
example, each point
represent a quantum state of
the ensemble in the phase space.
And of course now I have many,
many particles in my phase
space so I can do density.
I can do probability density so
that I introduce the particle
distribution function.
So the fn-- so this
one is a number
of particles p and rn, pn.
This is the N
particle, capital N,
I have N particles
in the system.
Distribution function--
And what it means is if I
this distribution function,
I multiply it by the
volume of this phase space
in this near that point,
rn pn, and that gives me
the number of systems,
in the ensemble having
the coordinate r
and p at time t.
So this one is my N particle
distribution function.
So as my time
evolves, now I'm going
to mix my time
with the ensemble.
As time evolves, the
system stage change.
That means issue of the ensemble
will also evolve in time--
each of the system
in the ensemble.
But see, because each system
started with a quantum state,
as time goes on, the two systems
can never have the same quantum
state, otherwise you go back--
if the [INAUDIBLE] is
the same, and you go back
[INAUDIBLE] time reversal,
you will be the same.
So what does that mean is
this each point, as time goes,
you form a streamline.
Now you can think
of fluid mechanics.
You form a streamline.
And this streamline
does not intersect.
It's actually
incompressible flow
in this n dimensional phase
space, 2n dimensional phase
space.
OK, if it's an
incompressible flow
and the particle
is conserved, you
can write actually an equation
of motion for this fn.
And fn is incompressible.
And if you think about if
you gone through 2 double 5,
2 double six, it derive actually
like a mature derivative,
all those stuff.
So you can do actually
differentiable volume.
You see what comes
in, what goes out,
what comes in, what goes out.
And because of the
incompressible,
so at the end, what
we have is an equation
for this distribution function.
What I have is df
N dt, this is time,
and then sigma i equals 1 to n.
And r times derivative,
so I will do a dot,
is dr dt because I'm
doing time evolution.
And df N dr N plus
i equals 1 to n.
And p times derivative--
No, I should not do i.
This is this i.
This is not n, because I'm
doing summation over i--
dp df N dp i.
And this is an
incompressible flow.
And this is essentially
the Liouville equation.
OK.
Nobody solves it.
It's hard to solve.
You have, if you think
about degree of freedom
is 2n [INAUDIBLE]
Avogadro constant.
But it's the start.
And from here, the physics is
branching into two directions.
And one is from here, one
is the Boltzmann equation.
And Boltzmann, how to go
from Liouville equation
to Boltzmann equation,
there are books,
a whole book devoted to
it, many, many layers
of approximation.
And [INAUDIBLE]
the three chapters
discussing Boltzmann equation.
And then there is also the
linear response theory.
And if you have enough
time, chapter 9, chapter 10,
chapter 9 for the start of
the linear response theory.
Boltzmann, of course, is
way earlier than Einstein.
And one of Einstein's motivation
in his PhD thesis was--
his PhD thesis was
on Brownian motion.
One is to use Brownian
motion determine
the atomic molecular size,
one of his motivation.
But another motivation is that
Boltzmann equation is the only
applicable to dilute a gas.
OK, so I said I can trade
parallel electron, phonon,
photon, molecules.
But I can't trade a liquid.
Liquid is not a dilute gas.
And what Einstein
started is trying
to develop a parallel
theory to Boltzmann.
So he is actually--
he laid the starting point of
this branch, linear response
theory.
And if you do
molecular dynamics,
this is actually the--
you start from
Liouville equation,
you don't try to simplify it.
You solve each atom.
Computer now becomes
more powerful.
So you can actually n
particle problem, F equals ma.
But see you have to
know, you need to know,
the linear response theory.
That's the foundation
for all the analysis.
And in fact, it's concept is
very easy to do F equal ma.
But how to get into
the understanding
is where that's the
theoretical foundation.
OK, so this is the
Liouville equation.
And also, there is
a very interesting,
if you go to, for example,
talk about how they entropy,
right, eventually come
out of those equations,
is still very heavily debated,
because most of those equation
is time reversal.
You put a negative time, it goes
back to your original point.
But entropy is not
the time reversal.
It's time increasing.
So that's another still
very confusing point.
So let's go from here
to Boltzmann equation.
We're not going to finish this.
And Boltzmann equation is a
tremendous simplification.
And here we have in
this Liouville equation,
I have an N particle
distribution function.
N is Avogadro constant.
What Boltzmann equation
does is one particle
of our distribution function,
from 10 to the 23rd down to 1.
That's a simplification.
That's many order.
That's why I say now there
are books are written on it.
And the Boltzmann equation is
defining the one particle now
is a f, t, r, and p.
Any particle that has
a location or r and p--
or maybe I can
just arrive this is
a-- let me start with one
particle rather than the t r1
p1.
And I generalized
r1 p1 because I
say just as any particle so rp.
And what it has is the
average of the overall other--
if I have 10 to 23rd particles,
so I average over the of 10
to the 23rd minus one particles.
So what I have is
in definition, is
I have the N factorial
and N minus 1 factorial.
And that is averaging over
all the outer particles.
So this is an F N. But then
I'm integrating our dr 2 to dr
N and dp2 dpN.
You can see I'm averaging all
the rest of the particles.
I say this is my one particle
distribution function.
And because of this,
now this particle,
other than a system
in the ensemble,
it never interacted with other
systems in the same ensemble.
It's a parallel,
incompressible, non interacting,
that's a lone wolf.
Now I'm one particle in
the system, in the system,
you will interact, they will
collide with other particles,
right?
So if you do your integration,
averaging over the lower
theorem, you get all the blob
of the outer particle, that's
the one particle
interacting with the other.
So what I have in
the equation is
the Boltzmann
equation is df, now
I do this f in general, say df
dt, I don't write a y anymore.
It's dr dt and delta rf,
this r is generalized
coordinate for one particle.
And the dp,
generalized momentum,
dt, and that the gradient
with respect to pf.
This is one particle I'm
averaging over other 10
to 23rd particles.
That averaging term is not 0.
And I'm putting here, right
now you just need to assemble--
that's the interaction.
That's my collision term of
this paragraph with the rest.
And this is halfway to
the Boltzmann equation.
So it's simplifying from 10 to
the 23rd, a huge lumber to 1
particle distribution function.
And of course dp dt
you can write f over m.
That's an a.
Then this p could be changing
to velocity, because that's
a derivative, whether
you write delta v f.
So if a dp dt is then times--
because the m, right--
p is in the d in
the denominator.
P is the mv.
So you can write
the m, 1 over m.
Or you can even write
into the quantum form k,
right p equals hk.
So it will be h bar times k--
no, 1 over h bar because this
one equal also is in terms of k
is 1 or h bar.
So there are different ways
to write this momentum term.
But the most complicated
is here, the interaction.
And I will discuss this
in the next lecture.
That's a very complex term.
But what I want to drop to
you is the Boltzmann equation
is based on, if one particle
distribution, the assumption,
if one part
distribution function,
you know all the other
particle distribution function.
And the reason is this
molecular chaos assumption.
So molecular chaos-- and
just to say the particles
do not really interfere
with each other.
They scatter, they interact.
But you know the distribution
function of one particle,
then you know all
the N particles.
So this is the N particle
distribution function.
t rn pn, that's all that we
want to write in the Liouville
equation
And molecular chaos is just
this is the f1 one t r1 p1
times the same t1 t rn pn.
So if I know this
distribution function
as a general function
of space momentum,
I know the all the N particle
distribution function.
So this is the--
it's an independent.
So you do have collision.
But after collision they
forgot where they came from.
The lost their memory.
It's molecular chaos.
That's a fundamental
in how you can
get from the Liouville
theory equation
to the Boltzmann equation.
OK, and just one more
comment, for example,
Boltzmann equation, when
you have dense fluids,
it doesn't apply.
So what people have
tried to modify
is actually do 2
particles and consider
final size of the molecule.
There's another equation
called the Anscombe,
which is a two-particle
distribution function.
But the equation became
very hard to handle.
Not many people ever solved it.
And so that's since the '60s
more effort were actually going
into the linear response,
because the computer became
available.
People can do computational
analysis and response theorem.
OK.